Mein Vortrag wird sich also mit der Frage der
digitalen Existenz über den Transhumanismus als
philosophische Herausforderung
befassen. Um einen Überblick zu geben, werde ich zunächst den
Transhumanismus aus
philosophischer Sicht vorstellen. Was ist also
der philosophische Inhalt des
Transhumanismus, auch des Posthumanismus?  Ich
werde diese Begriffe mit der gleichen Bedeutung verwenden, damit
wir vielleicht noch
zwischen ihnen unterscheiden können, aber ich denke, es ist zumindest
sehr verwandt, dann werde ich mich
auf den Begriff der Singularität konzentrieren und mich auf den Begriff der
Singularität konzentrieren, der große Aufmerksamkeit erlangt hat,
es ist das Schlüsselwort so  Um
in philosophischer Hinsicht für Beiträge und Transhumanismus zu sprechen,
werde ich
mit der Erörterung des Transhumanismus
als eine Art Technogeschichte fortfahren. Ich würde
es
Technogeschichte nennen  digitalen
Transhumanismus, dem wir gerade
begegnen, und schließlich werde
ich versuchen, eine Art Kritik am Transhumanismus zu formulieren,
damit er nicht gegen
Transhu ist  Manismus als solches aber nur gegen
Transhumanismus aus einem bestimmten
Blickwinkel, nämlich aus dem Konzept von Ray
Kurzweiler, der im Mittelpunkt meines
Vortrags steht, also haben wir zunächst einmal
diskutiert, ob Prometheus einer der
Ursprünge dieses Gedankens ist und bringt
Die Menschheit ist darauf aus
, mehr und mehr
Technologie, technologische Mittel und/oder
Möglichkeiten zu erlangen, sich selbst zu verbessern, so dass jeder
weiß, dass Prometheus das Feuer gestohlen
und zu den Menschen zurückgebracht hat, und
deshalb wurde
er schwer bestraft, und es gibt nämlich eine
modernere Version von Prometheus Nami
Frankenstein von Mary Shelley und
der zweite Titel heißt The Modern
Prometheus, was ich sehr
interessant fand, weil es aus dem 19.
Jahrhundert stammt und die Frage immer ist,
ob es eine Art Kontinuität zwischen modernem
Post- und Transhumanismus und antikem
Denken gibt. Ich denke, es könnte gute
Argumente geben  für diese These, weil Mary
Shelley sich im 19.
Jahrhundert darauf bezog, also ist hier ein Bild, das
Frankenstein zeigt  Als posthumanistisches
transhumanistisches Geschöpf ist dies sicher die
Frage zu dieser Zeit,
ähm, es waren keine digitalen Technologien
beteiligt, es war eine Art mechanische
Erfindung,
also haben sich seitdem viele Dinge
geändert,
also
ähm, da ist meine Definition von
Transhumanismus  Traditionelle menschliche
Perspektive, also plädiere ich in gewisser Weise für eine
Kontinuitätsthese, die Fiktion,
Science-Fiction, aber auch Hoffnung, Utopismus
und all den Perfektionismus umfasst. Ich denke, dies
sind integrale Bestandteile des transhumanistischen
Denkens, so dass der moderne Transhumanismus im
Hinblick auf das 20. Jahrhundert im Hinblick
auf die Digitalisierung ist  basiert auf der
biologischen Evolutionstheorie und
erweitert sie um eine technologische Theorie der
Illusion, also sind es zwei Evolutionstheorien
, die irgendwie verschmolzen sind, äh, also in dieser
Technologie konvergieren und verschmelzen Menschen und ähm Technologie mehr
und mehr, also ist das der Grund, warum ich
anrufe  Zumindest ist der moderne
Transhumanismus techno-teleologisch, also gibt es
ein Sagen Sie uns, es gibt ein Ziel, ein Ziel
, das ähm  die technik strebt an wie die
biologie sie anstreben könnte und ein
bestimmtes ziel und der transhumanismus
versteht technik meiner meinung nach als sich
selbst rechtfertigend also ist der transhumanismus a ist
technonormativ das heißt
äh der technologische fortschritt ist
ähm an sich
gut also
braucht er keinen  externe
Weisen der Technologiekritik, aber
richtig verstandene Technologie hat eine
eigene Teleologie und in dieser Entwicklung
hin zu einer besseren Stufe der
Menschheit,
und dies ist eine starke These, die
noch in Frage gestellt werden könnte, sie muss
meiner Meinung nach in Frage gestellt werden, also hier ist
das philosophische Problem  Wo sind die
moralischen Grenzen des Trans- und
Posthumanismus, wenn er technonormativ ist,
sollten wir nicht externe äh
Prinzipien einführen, die es uns ermöglichen, die Entwicklung zu bewerten
oder dazu führen können, dass der
Humanismus seine eigenen moralischen Standards durch schieren
technologischen
Fortschritt aufstellt, das bin ich
herausfordernd in diesem Vortrag, daher hier ein
Bild
von Ray Kurzwei, einer der
Hauptfiguren von S  Der Transhumanismus und
sein sehr einflussreiches Buch mit
dem Titel The Singularity Is Near und
der zweite Titel, den ich noch
aussagekräftiger
finde, lautet, wenn Menschen die Biologie transzendieren,
also finde ich diesen Begriff der
Transzendenz unserer biologischen Natur sehr entscheidend.
Hier ist ein weiteres Buch mit dem Titel The  Zeitalter
der spirituellen Maschinen Ich bespreche das
zweite Buch, wenn es um die Idee des
Hochladens von Gedanken geht. Was ist also die
Einzigartigkeit? Ich denke, dies ist das
Kernkonzept, das Schlüsselkonzept seiner Theorie.
Um Records-Datei enthält einige
Bilder und Tabellen,
die die
Entwicklung zeigen  Die Technologie wird
in der Zukunft erweitert, es wird also ein
Stand der technologischen Erfindung im
Jahr 2100 diskutiert, also ist dies natürlich nur eine
Spekulation, aber es ist eine interessante
Spekulation, weil sie argumentiert, dass
wir berechtigt sind, davon
auszugehen, dass dies um zwei im Jahr
2100 der Fall ist  Der technologische Fortschritt wird so
stark und so wichtig sein, dass etwas
Neues entstehen wird, nämlich die Singularität,
was das Ich bedeutet  rger der menschlichen Natur
und der Technik so und wir befinden uns natürlich
erst im Jahr 2020 und ihr seht
ähm also wir haben
sozusagen nur ähm die Kapazität eines
Mäusegehirns erreicht was technologische
Erfindung angeht also brauchen wir noch
etwas Zeit  Das menschliche Gehirn zu rekonstruieren
, argumentiert er, werden wir vielleicht im Jahr
2030 sehen. Ich meine, es ist eine neue Spekulation,
aber es ist ein interessantes Stück, weil
es sich auf
die Idee des exponentiellen Wachstums bezieht, das
eine besondere Natur hat, weil es am
Anfang kein sehr großes Wachstum ist
ein sehr
fast unmerkliches Wachstum, aber dann,
wenn wir weiter gehen, nimmt das
Wachstum stark zu, und das ist dies, das ist eine
Funktion des exponentiellen Wachstums, von dem er
behauptet, dass es die Grundlage unserer
technologischen Erfindungen ist
ein Buch geschrieben hat
ähm mit dem Titel Superintelligenz und
wer hält auch Gefahren von diesen äh
Erfindungen für
ähm also hier die Antwort auf die Frage
was die Singularität ist
um zitiert Datei immer, dass es eine
zukünftige Periode ist, in der das Tempo des
technologischen Wandels so schnell sein wird, dass
seine Auswirkungen so tiefgreifend sind, dass das menschliche
Leben irreversibel verändert wird, und er
argumentiert, dass seine These der
Singularität weder utopisch noch eine ferne Option ist, sondern
nur Realität ist  So wie es ist, ist es nicht,
es hat nichts mit
Science-Fiction zu tun, es ist eine interessante
Aussage, äh, diese Epoche wird
das Konzept, auf das wir uns verlassen, um
unserem Leben einen Sinn zu geben, von unseren
Geschäftsmodellen in den Kreislauf des menschlichen Lebens
einschließlich des Todes selbst verwandeln  Es ist also ein
Stand der Technik, eine technologische
Situation,
die alle unsere weltlichen Teile des Lebens revolutioniert oder stört,
und das ist der Grund, warum wir
neue Konzepte brauchen, die ich immer wieder als
interessante philosophische Aufgabe finde,
darüber nachzudenken, ob wir neue Begriffe prägen müssen
für neue Situationen neue technologische
Situationen, die so wichtig sind, dass
sie unser ganzes Leben umfassen, also ist dies
seine These und er argumentiert damit  Die
Singularität wird den
Höhepunkt der Verschmelzung unseres
biologischen Denkens und Seins mit
unserer Technologie darstellen, was zu einer Welt führt, die
immer noch menschlich ist, aber unsere
biologischen Wurzeln transzendiert, also ist es eine Transzendenztheorie,
es wird nach der Singularität keine Unterscheidung
zwischen Mensch und Maschine oder
zwischen geben  physische und virtuelle Realität, also ist
die Verschmelzung wichtig und dies ist der
Grund für die Notwendigkeit neuer Konzepte,
weil traditionelle Unterscheidungen, wie wir sie
gewohnt sind, an sie gewöhnt waren, äh
, werden nach der Singularität nicht mehr existieren, also
ähm, hier ist
ähm Aufzeichnungen, während unsere Antwort auf die
Frage, ob seine Theorie als posthuman bezeichnet werden sollte,
und er bestreitet sie,
weil er sagt, dass Menschsein für mich
bedeutet, Teil einer Zivilisation zu sein, die
versucht, ihre Grenzen zu erweitern, die wir
bereits über unsere Biologie hinaus erreichen, indem wir
schnell die Werkzeuge zur Neuprogrammierung erlangen
und  Erweitern Sie es, wenn Sie einen
durch Technologie modifizierten Menschen als nicht mehr
menschlich betrachten, wo würden wir die Definition ziehen
Linie, es ist ein Mensch mit einem bionischen Herzen,
immer noch ein Mensch, wie wäre es mit jemandem mit einem
neurologischen Implantat, wie wäre es mit zwei
neurologischen Implantaten, wie wäre es mit jemandem
mit 10 Nanobots in seinem Gehirn, also ist es
immer schwierig,
die Grenze zwischen
Prähumanismus oder Humanismus und
Posthumanismus I zu ziehen  stimmen Sie ihm zu, das ist
wirklich eine schwierige Aufgabe, also sollten wir nicht
argumentieren, dass wir als
Menschen immer gestellt und transhuman waren,
weil wir immer danach gestrebt haben
, unsere biologischen
Grenzen und Grenzen zu überschreiten
, also argumentiert er immer, dass unsere Fusion
mit Technologie hat Aspekte eines
rutschigen Abhangs, aber einer, der
zu größeren Versprechen abgleitet, nicht in
die Gewohnheiten der Natur, also hat er eine positive
Sicht auf technologische
Erfindungen und wird argumentiert, dass wir die
biologische Evolution insgesamt auf den Kopf stellen, das
ist ein interessanter Teil, also sind wir es  die neue
äh treibende kraft der evolution
sozusagen also haben wir macht über unseren
glauben gewonnen und sind nicht abhängig von der natur
a  Wir haben es bisher verwendet, also
hier sind einige Merkmale des
Transhumanismus, also ist es in gewisser Weise
spekulativ, weil er argumentiert, dass
informationsbasierte
Technologie innerhalb einiger Jahrzehnte alle menschlichen
Kenntnisse und Fähigkeiten umfassen wird,
ähm, das ist natürlich eine Spekulation, es ist
nur eine  Aussage und es ist nicht
sicher, ob wir auf die Dinge stoßen werden,
die er hier präsentiert, es ist
auch perfektionistisch und techno-optimistisch,
ähm er argumentiert, dass alles so beeindruckend
in vielen Aspekten ist, dass das Gehirn an
starken Einschränkungen leidet. Wir nutzen diese massive
Parallelität, um schnell subtile
Muster zu erkennen  Aber unser Denken ist extrem
langsam, die grundlegenden Neurotransaktionen sind
mehrere Millionen Mal langsamer als
moderne elektronische Schaltkreise,
was unsere physiologische Marke mit ihrer
Verarbeitung neuer Informationen extrem
begrenzt macht im Vergleich zu ihrem exponentiellen
Wachstum der gesamten menschlichen
Wissensbasis, so dass unsere Natur, sogar unsere Gehirnnatur,
inhärent ist  begrenzt und das ist der
Grund, warum wir ac  Laut Ray Crossfire
müssen wir unsere biologische Natur hinter uns lassen,
also
argumentiert er gegen den Pessimismus der Wissenschaftler,
weil er argumentiert, dass Wissenschaftler
sich immer mit
komplizierten Details befassen, wie er es nennt,
aber nicht den
langfristigen
Auswirkungen gewidmet sind, also sind sie es auch
engstirnig sozusagen und sie
sollten
sozusagen das Ganze betrachten und so ist es eine
Art techno-optimistischer Blick auf die
Digitalisierung, denn zumindest können
wir auch argumentieren, dass der
Transhumanismus in gewisser Weise transzendent ist,
weil er diese Singularität argumentiert
wird es uns ermöglichen, diese
Begrenzungen unseres biologischen Körpers und
Gehirns zu überwinden wir werden Macht über unseren Glauben erlangen
unsere Sterblichkeit wird in unseren Händen liegen wir
werden in der Lage sein so lange zu leben wie wir wollen also
sind dies viele interessante Versprechungen,
aber viele Versprechungen  Immer noch
spekulative Versprechungen, ja, also denke ich, dass
dies ein problematisches Merkmal des
Transhumanismus ist, zumindest wie die Rekrutenakte
es präsentiert, und das nenne ich
tec  hno Geschichte, weil Ray Kurzweil
zwischen sechs Apex unterscheidet
, sind wir, soweit er sagt, in der
vierten Epoche, die der Technologie gewidmet ist,
also haben die Menschen nicht
nur neuronale Muster entwickelt,
um von Beginn der
Evolution an, sondern sie haben
Technologie und Epoche erfunden  5
um bezeichnet die Verschmelzung von Technologie
und menschlicher Intelligenz, wie er
es in Bezug auf die Singularität beschreibt, aber dies
ist sozusagen nicht das Ende unserer Techno-Evolution
, es gibt eine weitere Epoche
, die auf das fünfte Buch folgt, nämlich Epic
6, das er das Erwachen des Universums nennt
und es ist ein Zustand des Universums, in dem sich
die menschliche Intelligenz
über das ganze Universum
ausbreitet und das Universum sozusagen mit Intelligenz füllt und unterstützt,
also
ist dies sozusagen das große Interesse oder
die
extremste Art, unseren Verstand zu erweitern  nämlich das
Füllen und den gesamten Kosmos,
also ist das sicherlich eine interessante Spekulation
und wir können fragen, wozu das gut ist,
wozu das gut ist, warum s  Sollten wir
uns auf der ganzen Welt verbreiten, aber es könnte ein
konsequenter Fortschritt sein, der
all diese Epochen ausdehnt, wissen Sie, auf
sehr konsequente Weise,
also habe ich dies als Techno-
Geschichte bezeichnet. Lassen Sie uns zu seinem anderen Buch übergehen,
das das Zeitalter der spirituellen
Maschinen heißt
Wie ich bereits sagte, argumentiert er, dass
es aufgrund technologischer Erfindungen keine Sterblichkeit mehr geben wird.
Der Grund für diese Unsterblichkeit ist,
dass wir unabhängig von unserem
Körper werden, und dies ist eine interessante Verbindung zu
dem anderen Gespräch, das wir gehört haben  Bisher
nämlich die Rolle des Körpers und
aller Puppen, also ähm Rayquaz-Datei
argumentiert, dass Trans- und Posthumanismus
eine Menschheit von ihren Körpern befreien sollten, ihre
Einschränkungen, äh, weil diese unsere
Sterblichkeit durch die
Langlebigkeit unserer Hardware gebunden waren  als die gebundene
Ausgabe zusammenbrach, war es das, also interpretiert er
unsere lebenden Körper als Hardware,
denn viele unserer Phobien verschlechterten die Hardware
allmählich, bevor sie sich
auflösten  Wir überqueren die Kluft, um
uns in unsere
Computertechnologie zu instanziieren. Unsere Identität wird auf
unserer sich entwickelnden Gedankendatei basieren. Wir werden
Software sein, nicht Hardware, also niemand,
nur Software. Das ist es, was
die
Menschheit zur
Menschheit macht. Es sind nur unsere Gedanken und
nicht unser Körper, denke ich  Wir können
diese Ansicht anfechten, weil ich denke, dass unser Körper
zu uns als Menschen gehört und wir
keine Menschen wären, nicht einmal gestellte Menschen
ohne unseren lebenden Körper, also wie können
wir diesen
ähm posthumanistischen Gedanken verstehen, tatsächlich ist es ein
Weg des Geistes, den er hochlädt
in seinem buch er schreibt er schreibt zitat als
software unsere sterblichkeit wird nicht mehr
vom überleben der rechnerschaltungen abhängig sein
es wird immer
noch hardware und körper geben aber die essenz ist schon
in ordnung und sie wird auf die
fortdauer unserer software umstellen  Es wird
die Hälfte geben, aber es wird alles ersetzt,
wenn es äh schwächer wird und äh nicht
mehr nützlich ist, so wie wir heute
unsere Akten nicht wegwerfen  Wenn
wir PCs wechseln, übertragen wir ihnen
zumindest die, die wir behalten wollen, also werfen wir
auch unsere Gedankendatei nicht weg, wenn
wir uns regelmäßig auf den
neuesten noch leistungsfähigeren
PC portieren. Ist die Zukunft dieser Menschheit also wirklich
geteilt?  und
über die neueste Hardware bezweifle ich das,
aber er argumentiert immer noch, dass
Computer natürlich nicht die diskreten Objekte sein werden, die
sie heute sind, sie werden
tief in unsere Körper, Gehirne und Umgebungen eingebettet sein,
unsere Identität und unser Überleben, von denen
wir letztendlich unabhängig werden  Das
Herz Wenn es ums Überleben geht, wird unsere
Unsterblichkeit eine Frage der
Sorgfalt sein, häufige Backups zu erstellen. Wenn
Sie in dieser Hinsicht nachlässig sind, müssen wir
eine alte Gepäckkopie laden und sind dazu verdammt
, unsere jüngste Vergangenheit zu wiederholen
, weil unsere Existenz und Identität
an bloße Software gebunden ist,
äh das Versagen, unseren Verstand zu stützen,
wird dazu führen,
dass wir äh sozusagen altmodisch sind und dass wir in der Lage sind,
unser l zu wiederholen  Wenn wir sozusagen unsere Zukunft verloren haben
und wir sie ja wieder verlassen müssen,
ist dies eine der
Konsequenzen, wenn sein Verstand Argumente hochlädt.
Ja,
ja, das ist also sein Projektor
Daher werde
ich meinen Vortrag mit einer kurzen Kritik des Transhumanismus abschließen,
zumindest so, wie
Ray Kurzwein ihn entwickelt hat. Mein
Argument ist also, dass Transhumanismus
Realität mit Illusion verwechselt, weil er
argumentiert, dass Zitat als virtuelle Realität
aus dem Nervensystem
heraus mit der Realität konkurriert  Realität in
Bezug auf die Auflösung Glaubwürdigkeit unsere
Erfahrungen werden zunehmend
in virtuellen Umgebungen stattfinden in der virtuellen
Realität können wir
sowohl körperlich als auch emotional eine andere Person sein Tatsächlich können
andere Menschen wie Ihr
Liebespartner einen
anderen Körper für Sie auswählen als Sie
wähle selbst aus, also ist das auf meine
Art nur Illusion, also müssen wir
noch zwischen Realität und Übel unterscheiden  usion
und das hat auch damit zu tun, dass wir unsere moralische
Bewertung dessen, was in der virtuellen
Realität passiert, als Mias Illusion verstehen,
müssen wir noch sozusagen von der realen Realität unterscheiden. Ein
weiteres Problem, das
ich sehe, ist, dass der Transhumanismus das Leben
zumindest in Bezug auf Software auf Software reduziert  sehr
zitiert Dateien Version und Transhumanismus
verwechselt Technologie mit Moral, wie
ich zu Beginn meines Vortrags gesagt habe,
Transhumanismus ist techno-normativ,
also rechtfertigt der technologische Fortschritt
Moral, und ich denke, das
ist nicht wahr, also
braucht technologischer Fortschritt immer
eine externe Haltung  Um es zu bewerten,
können technologische Erfindungen nicht
das Maß für ihre eigene Entwicklung sein,
wir brauchen externe Perspektiven auf
sie. Höhere Technologie bedeutet nicht,
dass die Menschheit moralisch verbessert wird
unmoralische Handlungen zum
Beispiel
um den Oxforder Philosophen
um Luciano floridi hat c  Ich habe den Begriff
des künstlichen Übels für eine neue Art von Übel
verwendet,
die durch die
Entwicklung der Digitalisierung ins Leben gerufen wird, sodass wir immer
über die negativen Folgen unserer technologischen Innovation diskutieren müssen,
was bedeutet, dass der technologische Fortschritt
seine eigenen Gefahren hat und
diese Gefahren nicht bewältigen kann  sozusagen von innen also
ist dies wieder ein spieler für
äh eine äußere haltung entwickeln eine
äußere haltung gegenüber
technologischer innovation etablieren ja das
war bisher meine argumente vielen dank
für die aufmerksamkeit und ich freue
mich auf die diskussion meiner these